at some point the houston texans will
indeed be done with desean watson it was
one of the biggest stories early in the
off
season it became a big story in a very
different way
as of march 16 when we became aware
thanks to desean watson's twitter
account
of the first of what would be 22
lawsuits filed against them alleging
misconduct during
massage therapy sessions the texans
for the most part have been very very
quiet about the matter there was a slip
there was a lapse
from new coach david culley on a podcast
back in march
after that they got david cully on board
with
the talking point which is no talking
about deshawn watson but nick casario
was on the i think it's the flagship
houston sports station for the texans
talking about watson and he recited the
party line but chris he said
something else that caught my attention
let's listen to what casirio had to say
yesterday about watson and then we'll
try to make sense of it
i think we're taking it one day at a
time um really control the things that
we can control i think the players have
been focused on
on their attitude and their approach in
the building and they've handled
everything i would say very well again i
really have any additional comments
about anything
i think we're respectful of what's
happening we're respectful of the
process of it
and everybody that's involved so again
the most important thing is for all of
us
um you know our coaches and players
myself included
you know to focus on the things that we
can control and as we get more
information as we get closer to training
camp then we'll try to make
you know the best decision for the
houston texans whatever that entails
and there it is thanks to seth payne and
sean pendergast for drawing that out of
him
as we get closer to training camp we'll
try to make the best decision
for the houston texans what what
decision do you make
what what decisions are available to you
if you're the texans
you keep him and see what happens you
trade him
even if the 22 lawsuits aren't resolved
you trade him if the 22 lawsuits are
resolved
or you cut him those are the four
options cut
off the table at a minimum they'll trade
him for whatever they can get
with the 22 lawsuits pending but chris i
think that the crux of this for the
texans
and this is one of the reasons why the
personal lawyer for owner cal mcnair
tried to broker settlement
weeks ago and eventually the texans had
to acknowledge that
in an si article
they don't want to have to make a
decision
about trading him with the 22 cases
pending
because they're going to get less if
they trade him then definitely but the
other side of that coin is
he shows up gets put on paid leave while
the cases continue
to be litigated and they pay him 10
million dollars this year
and he's not on the team that's what
they have to decide are we willing to
pay him 10 million
yeah and and hold the right to trade him
until after the season
or do we just take what we can get for
him now and let someone else pay him 10
million to potentially not play this
year
yeah i i uh it's it's a tough decision
there's no doubt about that i mean it's
the 10 million dollar question
i don't i mean i don't have an answer
here
but i i do think that like what what i
would say
with this scenario desean watson you
know taking everything in
as good as he is as a football player
you know we've talked about it so much
he's
arguably top five quarterback in
football if not he's
six or seven i mean he's right there
he's one of the best in the game
he's got a lot of years in his prime i
if you gave me those
boiled it down to those two scenarios
right there mike
and if i'm cal mcnair and nick casario
and i feel somewhat comfortable
about whatever that we can afford the 10
million dollars on the
commissioner exempt list we can afford
it it's not going to be a big blow to
our team this year
as far as anything else or the future
then i'm holding on to deshawn watson
for the year or to when this gets set up
because i'm not just trading desean
watson
to get rid of them uh while like you
said there's 22 cases pending and now
you're trading them away and it's for
who knows what at that point
because you're right it's damaged goods
to a degree so i would be more inclined
to say you know what
we're okay at quarterback for this year
we didn't really expect to have them
anyways
we're gonna have them here and then
we're gonna wait to the off season
until we can get multiple teams involved
in this conversation and get their heads
wrapped around this
and now we can start trying to get the
best trade offers we can possibly get
and my understanding is if the cases are
resolved the trade value and the trade
interest
is much much higher there still is trade
interest because there's out there
thinking we can
we can snatch him right for a lot less
than what we would have to give up if
these cases weren't pending and we're
willing
to pay the 10 million if it comes down
to it
because that's just the investment that
you pay that's your loss leader because
you got a franchise quarterback when
this stuff
all goes away on the back end and part
of this too chris
that has vexed teams in the past as it
relates to guys like antonio brown
the league isn't exactly forthcoming
when it comes to the whole concept of
whether or not it will use paid leave
now maybe
cal mcnair has a source in the league
office
that will tell cal you know what
yeah we're going to end up putting him
on paid leave or not
that people assume he's automatically
going to be put on paid leave
he's facing no criminal charges
he has 22 lawsuits pending against him
but none of them have resulted in any
type of indictment or criminal action
and when you look at the personal
conduct policy and we wrote something
about this weeks ago
i looked at it i broke it down now hey
the the discretion is there to do
whatever they want to do because the
commissioner's
investigation results in a belief that
the
player may have violated the policy he
can be put on paid leave well that's
pretty broad
but when you remember remember this
chris tony busby the lawyer for the 22
plaintiffs
at one point expressed that that some of
his clients who had been
questioned by the league as part of
their investigation yeah
felt like they weren't being respected
that tells me that they were subjected
to
pretty s tough aggressive and maybe
skeptical questioning right
which which maybe the league thinks they
didn't hold up well maybe the league
thinks that that maybe it's
it's it's not as as
as it's being told or it doesn't rise to
the level
of what they think it does and maybe
they think we can't in good conscience
put him on paid leave just because
there's 22
if 22 cases individually aren't that
strong it doesn't matter if there's 22
or 222
if they're if if each one of them isn't
regarded as strong
yes doesn't matter so i we've just
assumed he's going to be on paid leave
i don't know that that's a fair
assumption which means and i've made
this case
too there's a chance he ends up playing
for the texans this year he shows up
thinking he's going to be put on paid
leave and he isn't
i i mean i know mike i you know i i know
i've been one to say really from
for a while now that i think there's a a
a faction in the league that
thinks this might you know get resolved
the way
you're talking you know that's why i
think there's teams that are continuing
to be
interested here you know yeah they maybe
that they don't believe that the 22
charges are quite as severe or what they
appear to like what you're saying there
i have a hard time believing that 22 of
those cases
will all be you know oh it's
you know not credible or you know you're
questioning it
suspect there and how they answered
whatever blah blah blah i have a hard
time with that
and then just history in the nfl i mean
i feel like we've seen people go on the
commissioner exempt list for
for far less or at least or at least far
less as far as the surrounding
circumstances and everything like that
so i'd have a home they have criminal
charges no no you're right washington's
example is typically only used when you
have criminal charges i was specifically
thinking about
like um yeah you're right but i mean we
saw
we saw ezekiel elliott get suspended
right there he got suspended he wasn't
put on the commissioner exemplar but
there was no
criminal charges there either right and
no lawsuit right
they did there oh that's what i'm trying
to say yeah sorry yeah right but but
that that's the actual suspension that
could be imposed at the back end of the
process gotcha and and i think deshaun
watson at some point is
facing when you look at the parallels
between his situation and ben
roethlisberger's from 11 years ago
right i think at a minimum he's facing
some type of intervention by the league
that would include a suspension
that's when it's all said and done paid
leave is the thing that they basically
use to take the heat out of the hot
kitchen it's a pr
device we can't have someone who's been
accused of these heinous crimes
or or serious misconduct
on the field during our games so we're
going to take that guy
we're going to put him on the sideline
we're going to put him out of the
building we're going to leave him home
and he's still going to get paid and the
league has always
believed and argued and contended that
that's not punishment of the player
which is a
ridiculous proposition football players
want to play football
football players are chasing their
legacy just because they get their money
doesn't make them feel like they've not
been punished but the league has always
thought no big deal no big deal we're
not punishing them right yes yes you are
yeah punishing the guy
but they're willing to use it because
they don't want to have that guy
in the building on the sideline on the
field
and have people notice shield yeah
here's the guy here's the guy that's
been accused of these things even though
he's supposedly innocent until proven
guilty
we don't want him around just because of
the accusations it really is wrong when
you think about it it really is
yeah so much for innocent until proven
guilty yeah right uh but but they they
claimed you know they do their threshold
investigation if it's going to be fair
and if they come to the conclusion that
we don't think
this is the big deal that the
individual's alleged to be we've done
enough of an investigation come to the
conclusion that you know there's only
two of the 22 that are claiming
any type of forcible misconduct and we
don't know whether or not they've
cooperated so far
we don't know which of the ones have
spoken i there's a way
through these weeds if the league does a
fair and appropriate job of applying its
policy there is a way that he doesn't
get put on
the commissioner exempt list and you
know if the league is willing to tell
the texans
maybe the league is willing to tell some
other team that would then trade for him
knowing that he's not going to be on the
commissioner exempt list and we're
comfortable with him being on the field
this year yeah well then open up the
floodgates or at least the teams that
have any questions about you know their
quarterback situations in general
i mean i think if we got close enough
here and you got to at least like
training camp within the first week to
10 days of training camp really
i mean if this became okay wait it seems
like the desean watson thing is gonna
get settled or
you know there's light at the end of the
tunnel then then i think you're gonna
see
a team like miami and denver jump back
in the conversation
i i i do i would expect that he's too
good it's like aaron rodgers like we
talked about i mean once it becomes
available
teams are going to come out of the
woodworks trying to figure out how they
can figure out to get a guy like this
so it's all going to be dependent on
where he stands with the league and
everything like that
but like all right just getting back to
the original question because i would
like to hear your opinion on this too a
little bit
with him in the commissioner exempt list
right and all that stuff say let's say
it does go down that way
mike like you know it's they don't quite
have it figured out
he shows up at texans training camp like
you said they said go home you're on
paid leave blah blah blah whatever
i mean if there was teams that were
still
interested in trading at that point you
know are
if you're the texans would you do it at
that point would you
or would you say you know what we're
just going to hold on to the year like i
said and just go we'll
we'll bite the bullet on the 10 million
and we'll wait till we can really strike
a strike at rich next year
well the texans were the ones who
basically
you know gave away a second round pick
to get 16 million off their books yeah
they started this trend right right
to avoid paying 16 million dollars to
brock osweiler
they gave up a second round pick
so to avoid paying 10 million to desean
watson
knowing that he's never going to play
for you again anyway
what would you take for desean watson
knowing that you once gave up a
two to avoid paying a guy 16 million
i think that's part of the analysis and
that's the reality
these draft picks have a cash value and
everyone is going to view it differently
but
but that i think that that will help
them get to a point where
they they can assess the situation and
make as nick casario said the best
decision
for the houston texans it's going to
depend upon
most importantly are the cases settled
are they not settled and maybe as we get
closer to camp
deshawn watson and his lawyer rusty
hardin are thinking maybe we don't need
to
get these settled you know at some point
i think it's
fair for watson harden
texans eagles broncos
dolphins yes i think those are the three
teams right that would be inclined yep
to say to the league you can't just hold
this
over to sean watson's head because
you're holding it over our heads too
we're trying to figure out what we're
going to do this season with our
football teams so you're either going to
put them on the commissioner exempt list
you know or you're not don't play the
antonio brown game now i think they did
it to antonio brown
because it was a way to keep him out of
the league
without pay without putting him on an
unpaid suspension
he's available the patriots cut him
right he'd been accused of some
wrongdoing
fully investigated right multiple things
right so
all the league has to say well we don't
know if he'll put him on the
commissioner example listen it scared
everyone away
as a practical matter 14-game unpaid
suspension yeah i think it's different
with desean watson
because the texans are on the hook for
10 million and the texans are in a
position where they can trade him and oh
by the way he is a pretty exciting
player
whatever the league has done by way of
investigating this
if they are comfortable with desean
watson playing
they need to tell the texans
and any other interested team yeah he's
you know what
he's fine or just announce to the world
we've investigated this and based upon
the current information and the
individuals who have cooperated with
us and in light of the fact that several
haven't we have no basis for putting him
on paid leave and we will await the
outcome of these cases
before we take any further action why
not do that
i i i hear you i i mean i i think that's
not a bad scenario i mean the nfl's got
to be careful here that's for sure
i mean i think the one thing that like
of all the things you just said there
that jumped out to me to where i went
ooh
you know if these aren't resolved and
they just let desean watson play
i i just can't imagine that happening i
can't i think the nfl is like
way too hyper aware of like their
standing in society
and all the things that are perceived he
hasn't been charged with
i know how can you do that i know but
i'm just until proven guilty he's not
even accused of being guilty
mike don't don't don't i'm just just i'm
not i'm just i know i hear you
you're right a hundred percent but i'm
just going through the the history of
the nfl and then where we are like
currently at the at
society right now i just don't think nfl
is going to be willing to take the
the the brunt of that every day
wow they're just going to let some star
quarterback hell you know because that's
what it's going to get turned into
star quarterback can do whatever he
wants in that league they don't care
he's abused women and those things it's
it'll take a life of its own if he's out
there in the field
and that's where i think the nfl
ultimately will not want to have those
images out there
so this becomes the number one topic in
in the nfl again
and your instincts are right because
all due respect i've been studying
this aspect of the way the league
handles off-field misconduct
for years yeah it it it isn't always
about
right and wrong right it isn't always
about truth and justice
it isn't always about respecting the
constitutional rights of the individuals
it's about public relations the whole
thing is about public relations
the entire personal conduct policy the
in-house justice system that has cropped
up in
the wake of the ray rice situation where
the league basically says
we're no longer going to defer to what
the criminal justice system does
because sometimes they get it wrong at
least for our purposes right
they put the guy in a diversion program
when there's this video lurking around
of him knocking out his then fiance that
video comes out
turns our business upside down so that
it is
pr driven period and that's why
all sorts of things can happen that you
would look at and say well it's just not
fair
to the individual involved especially if
the houston police department
has been talking to these individuals
multiple of the 22
persons have spoken to the houston
police department
you can charge me or not yeah that's
right and and i'd like to think the nfl
has sources around the
various departments and agencies
involved that they can find out which
way the wind's blowing i'd like to think
they have that
capacity the resources to do that
i just i think it's fair to the player
um
you know the player has rights and the
player has a right to play football
unless and until there's sufficient
proof that he's done something that
should prevent him from playing football
and i and and that's that's not a
comment on the merits
i'm just saying at some point yeah
that's right at some point it's time to
go back to work
right and if you're going to keep them
from working you better have a good
reason to do it yeah that's all i'm
saying
yeah no i i mean i i agree with you it
is unfair
but you know that that's also where the
nfl goes into it's a privilege to play
in this league and we're going to
protect the shield and all those type of
things that we know
that we hear all the time that we roll
our eyes with sometimes
but that this is exactly what they mean
and where this comes from
and uh that's that's where i just i
can't imagine it
i don't i don't see it happening um you
know especially with you know hashtag me
too
being so popular within the last year
there's just a lot of circumstances
you know in the world in the league that
i think ultimately if it's not decided
clearly
i i just i can't see it happening i
can't and it's not it's not
it's not just a popular hashtag it's a
long overdue record but no doubt about
it i don't mean to
i don't want to i don't know you know i
know we're on the same team here i'm i'm
not
disagreeing with you i'm making sure
people understand where we're coming
from
there are delicate and important issues
embedded within the merits of the claims
being made exactly sean watson
those need to be handled properly and
i've said all along he needs to settle
these cases not just to make him go away
quietly he needs to have his reckoning
he needs to make
make good with the people who believe
that their rights were violated and the
way that you get your justice through
the civil justice system
is through the payment of money that's
how it works
these individuals chose initially to
file a lawsuit when you file a lawsuit
you seek the recovery of monetary
damages
to compensate you for what you have
endured
he should and i've said this for weeks
he should work out
a fair settlement with each of those 22
individuals so they believe
that their rights have been respected
that that is part of this but what we're
trying to
what we're trying to do here is separate
that
from the employment rights that desean
watson has
as it relates to the nfl and at some
point the nfl has an obligation
to get into the weeds sufficiently
to make a decision a fair decision a
proper decision
and an inherently difficult decision
is desean watson allowed to continue to
come to work
while these cases are unresolved and
will we wait until they are resolved
to pass final judgment on whatever
unpaid suspension we would levy against
him that's the question
and we'll see what the league does but i
hope they take it seriously
i trust that they will but i know based
upon
past examples
like ezekiel elliott yeah right i feel i
feel like they
i feel like they decide what they want
to do yeah
and they work backward through whatever
facts may
may dispute the end result
they work backward to justify where they
want to go
yeah i mean well listen at the end of
the day i think the nfl is going to do
what's best for the nfl i think that's
what we're saying
they're going to do whatever they deem
necessary for the best of the league the
shield
all those type of things and yeah with
that sometimes you know
personal care gets thrown by the wayside
and and really yeah
basic work rights but that's i guess
part of what we signed as players in the
cba and things like that that they're
they're gone a little bit from from that
standpoint and that's what i expect the
nfl to do so we'll see where it goes and
i just can't imagine a team you know
even if they do feel like they're going
to get it for the low or something like
that
wanting to trade and you know even for
the low for desean watson is still going
to be
something substantial to trade and then
not have these things resolved and be
like oh well we hope it all
turns out the right way and we hope
there's not one that
ends up being serious and there's
something substantial there
that's another like like i just don't
see that avenue
opening up or happening i think there
might be dabbling but i can't imagine a
team actually pulling the trigger on
that one
easy solution if you're willing to tie
up multiple picks
because they would be yeah tied to the
the conditions
it's it's based on how many games he
plays yeah sure sure this year yeah it's
that's it if he plays four or fewer
it's this pick in 2022 if he plays
you know four to ten it's that pick if
he plays ten or more it's a first round
or you could do it
you could you could tie 22 23 24 draft
picks
to how many games he plays this year and
next year if you're but the problem is
if you're the team that's trading for
him you tie your own hands as it relates
to what you can do with those picks in
other trades because you got to keep
them
available for however the final analysis
goes of the
watson deal but but the point is this
with the this
this entire conversation flows from the
thing nick casario said
at the end of his answer they are going
to make the best decision for the texans
as they get closer to camp which means
they understand there is a decision to
be made
and this thing that has gone dormant at
least as it relates to football
purposes and these assumptions we've
made we're not going to see deshaun
watson those assumptions could be wrong
we may be seeing him
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports